this video is brought to you by magic
spoon
what's up wisecrack michael here today
we're talking about one of our all-time
favorite shows and how that show screwed
up a bit
nothing too touchy right jesus somebody
a little help archer quickly became one
of our most beloved shows thanks to its
quickfire banter
you know how bad that is for your
eardrums what i said do you know
drive the damn car oh wonderfully
psychotic characters how does it feel to
be a
murderer shall we find out
and die hard commitment to chaos and
filth i don't have cockporn just laying
around
but popularity is a bit of a
double-edged sword for a tv series
higher ratings create more pressure for
the show to run and run
making it harder and harder for the
writers to pump out top tier television
that doesn't get boring
and some shows crumble under this weight
you know what you need
solitude flash mob to its credit archer
has been pretty
fearless in its attempts to solve this
problem but still
something went wrong rest assured we're
not going on some
anti-archer tirade we respect that the
show completely
overhauled itself on numerous occasions
in increasingly bold ways but weirdly
the more archer changed the more it kind
of
stayed the same and usually for the
worse lana
introspection is the enemy of happiness
so
my advice is don't always work for me
has it though i don't know
that's the beauty no really and we'll
explain why in this wisecrack edition on
archer
what went wrong and spoilers for archer
ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor the
product that has fueled today's video
magic spoon cereal when i was a kid i
used to love eating cereal but i had to
give it up because as i got
older it started to make me feel awful
it tasted like pure sugar and would
always leave me feeling sick
not exactly how you want to start your
day magic spoon is a serial for us
olds that aren't yet facebook commenters
but also aren't hopping on the latest
tick tock trend
it comes in four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
and with a variety pack you can try them
all it tastes
amazing and i love that it has no sugar
11 grams of protein
and only three net grams of carbs in
each serving
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb
and gmo free which basically means
you'll actually feel good after eating
it
if you don't believe me then you have to
try it out for yourself click the link
in the description to grab a variety
pack today
when you're there use the promo code
wisecrack at checkout to get free
shipping
or go to magicspoon.com wisecrack magic
spoon is so confident in their cereal
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money
no questions asked so click the link
below and use the code wisecrack for
free shipping
or go to magicspoon.com wisecrack now
back to the show to figure out what went
wrong we have to figure out what went
right
by adam reed's own admission archer is
essentially a workplace comedy
even if it doesn't look like one at
first glance whether they're stealing
diamonds or selling cocaine
the members of isis are always steeped
in office drama there are workplaces
defined by gossip
grudges and petty rivalries also flex
accounts it's only 630
for my goddamn flex account
hr complaints and who's screwing who and
if you
want to have ball slappy sex with me on
cyril's desk
please line up and take a number
you hurt the lady so just like any other
workplace on tv really
except with far more weapons training
and far less impulse control
uh pam i will end you while there is
lots of high drama going on during each
episode of archer
assassination attempts high profile
heists and countless deaths
it is all treated with exactly the same
casual disregard and mild irritation
with which your usual workplace tv
characters confront conflict
as a result archer gets to function like
a typical workplace comedy
even if the workplace itself is atypical
yeah but then i wouldn't get to hang out
with everybody at work
you hate everybody at work i know it's
the only thing that gets me out of bed
every morning
setting a sitcom in an office works well
for tv because of how naturally
unchanging it is
whether it's a traditional office like
well the office or a failing bar like
it's always sunny in philadelphia
or a police department like brooklyn 99
the setting acts as a kind of
bubble fossilizing the characters over
time the same people clock in
at the same time each day make the same
complaints about their job and get drawn
into the same arguments and flirtations
with the same
colleagues all of this i've heard all of
this before no
shut up bird it makes the fictional
workplace relatable
while also letting the show reset itself
after each
episode this repetition can also
highlight just how psychologically stuck
characters
are for sterling this means drinking
screwing and shooting himself into a
state of emotional numbness
every member of the team is the worst
version of themselves on repeat
mallory manipulates everyone around her
so that she can feel in control cyril
desperately tries to break free of his
beta male image and
lana is forever caught between her
revulsion and attraction to archer
their inability to break with their own
patterns both provides a constant source
of comedy
and makes them feel real albeit hugely
messed up
they are continually undone by the same
weaknesses
just like we all are of course we do see
the characters manage to diverge from
their well-worn paths from time to time
even if only a little archer is
willfully obtuse to the point that the
vast majority of his bad behavior
never comes back to haunt him as a
result he is highly resistant to
learning
any sort of lesson from anything no i
don't think it's a trap
although i never do and it very often is
however every so often we catch a
glimpse of the person hiding
under sterling's tough facade like when
we learn about his troubled upbringing
that left him emotionally damaged
and he has moments with lana and mallory
which show that they do
genuinely care about each other even if
they never last that long
just like i taught you without any help
from whoever your father is
yeah you were always there for me which
i never really thank you for
archer's character is also rounded out
with revelations about his fear of
alligators or his attitude towards
death bit by bit these little details
combined with his constant willful
disregard for his own safety
paint a picture of someone who isn't
just your standard cartoon sitcom
[ __ ] but a guy who has a thoroughly
and fascinatingly messed up relationship
with his own mortality
oh so suddenly you don't have a death
wish lana i've never had a death wish
it's just that i don't believe that i
personally
even can die with the employees of isis
it's these
incremental bits of growth which give
them their depth and make them more than
just walking punch lines
rather than random zaniness their jokes
often play off their own psychology and
histories
pretty sure the nazis had scientists no
they didn't
that's why we they lost the war this
kind of joke-laden character development
is a prominent feature of other
successful long-running comedies
like it's always sunny in philadelphia
this is gay marriage
that's two dudes banging each other
i don't know where i fit in as a gay man
and it's starting to get to me but
despite the changes there is still a
strong element of repetition for the
whole archer is marked with these slow
developments
pam steadily grows from the group's
punching bag to one of its most
formidable agents archer is continually
forced to re-examine his relationships
as new situations emerge
like when lana reveals that she's
pregnant a pregnant woman
or when pam also turns out to be like
the pele of casual sex
well how do you think that makes me feel
i don't care
pam now having said that would you
please come in this dirty toilet stall
and have sex with me
for the first few seasons archer had a
firm grasp on how to drive the show
forward in this way
keeping the core dynamics largely intact
while moving the pieces around
just enough to keep things interesting
and being a cartoon
it felt free to play a little fast and
loose with the continuity flip-flopping
on certain changes rey was in and out of
a wheelchair
cheryl was different kinds of crazy on
different days etc even the introduction
of the wee baby sheamus
legally but not biologically archer's
son provided the perfect way for the
show to flirt with the idea of daddy
sterling without having to actually
commit to it before giving him a child
of his own a few seasons later
sterling archer mimi i'd like you to
meet your daughter
abba jean this flirtation is pretty
standard the unwillingness to commit to
any permanent changes often see sitcoms
locked in never ending will they or
won't they scenarios because these offer
more flexibility for example
if two characters actually couple up the
show has to find a new funny direction
to take them in so shows like archer
will largely flirt with consequences
rather than actually see them play out
health scares like archer's cancer
battle will pop up and then quickly go
away
okay so remember when you had cancer
um vaguely while office romances like
his ongoing connection to lana
tend to find themselves endlessly in
limbo and
here's where things can start to go
wrong at a certain point
no matter how great the show this can
become stale
as much as we like the comforting
familiarity we eventually get bored
archer is pretty explicitly aware of
this problem with characters cracking
meta jokes about their fear of things
becoming too repetitive
most notably through the beloved
phrasing jokes are we not saying
phrasing anymore
guys we really need to talk about
getting phrasing back in the rotation
while other shows have tried to fend off
the sense of staleness by introducing
new love interest or job changes
archer went all in and decided to shift
settings entirely
with archer vice the show threw out the
retro spy thriller template and went off
on a cocaine-fueled jungle bender since
the government has unjustly accused us
of treason we are now forced to transfer
those skills from espionage to criminal
activity
kind of like the a-team but we sell
drugs although
it proved to be something of a mixed bag
the new setting allowed for the
characters to evolve in
all kinds of bizarre new directions like
pam's transformation into an
uncontrollable coke fiend and so from
season 5 on archer basically began
an ongoing cycle of radical change in
reset the crew returns to being spies
for a while and then gets busted by the
us government
forcing them to shift gears again with
the coma seasons though is where things
start to really go
wrong archer puts its faith completely
in genre hopping
delving into archer's unconscious mind
as a way to transplant the show to a
different
era entirely and hey is it all that
different from the genre hopping the
show
is already done from hardboiled noir to
zany space adventures each new season
saw the characters reimagined to fit
their new setting
on paper this actually seems very smart
what better way to counter sitcom
boredom than by making each new season
as different as possible
but what actually happens when archer
goes into a coma and the characters we
know and love go from 1940s la to outer
space
nothing great to be honest the coma
seasons basically detach
all the characters from any sort of
continuity because these characters are
just figments of archer's imagination
who look
and act like his colleagues watching how
each character fits into the new setup
provides lots of room for creativity and
humor both in how they change
and how they stay the same some
characters are reimagined as monsters
animals and robots while cyril remains a
nebbish dork no matter the context
but everything that happens is also
essentially inconsequential because for
three whole seasons
we know it will all be erased when
archer wakes up
this doesn't inherently make for bad
television in fact such an approach can
really work
the sopranos famously used frequent
dream sequences and even a pair of
comatose episodes
in which tony imagined himself in a
completely different life
much like our catatonic spy but these
episodes worked because while nothing
tony saw was real
they offered us a deeper look into his
psyche and added to our understanding of
his journey through the real world
the moral of that story basically if
you're going to set a narrative so that
it's literally inside the protagonist's
head
you need to have something to say about
what's going on in there
don't get us wrong archer's dreamy
seasons do achieve this at times
keeping certain aspects of the show in
place while everything else shifts
around
underscores some of the show's essential
truths for example
no matter the time period or
circumstance archer finds himself
irresistibly drawn to lana in these
moments the show tells us who the
characters really
are by showing us the parts of
themselves they just can't seem to get
away from
and at times the more out their settings
even provide
interesting ways to develop them like
when cheryl has sex with a literal
doomsday device you may have some
unhealthy associations with sex and
death
but again it's archer's own psyche and
not cheryl's
so who cares what's more
these insights are unfortunately few and
far between
for the most part the change of scenery
just makes it easier for the show to
retell
old jokes resetting every character to a
generic model which can be jammed into
the new story
allows them to repackage old gags like
krieger's creepiness
and cyril's surprising
it also sees the show tend towards a
degree of flanderization with most of
its cast flanderization is the process
in which a character becomes
increasingly defined by a single trait
like how in the simpsons ned flanders
went from a gentle nature do-gooder who
happened to be religious to a full-blown
religious zealot
everyone is beautiful yes but jesus said
that
pretty much the same thing darn it the
bible said the devil would be attractive
similarly pam's years of hard-won status
and self-confidence
are suddenly snapped back so that she
can return to being the go-to gross out
punchline becoming a literal monster
during the gang's
season in space by extracting them from
any larger narrative
the show quickly reduces its characters
to little more than a series of
exaggerated quirks and overused
catchphrases
archer and all of his friends are left
basically catatonic
still alive but frozen in place the
truth is that
rather than solving the boredom which
can seep in as a sitcom runs on for
multiple seasons
archer's wild genre jumping acted as a
way of cheating or disguising
the very problems it was trying to
escape it frees the show from having to
keep its characters in motion
interesting avenues like archer's
parenthood or his attempts to be a
faithful partner
are abandoned so that the show doesn't
have to figure out what the hell to do
with him in this new context
while the setting and genre might change
the interior lives of the characters
remain
totally static rather than solving the
problem of sitcom stasis the coma
seasons basically just dress it up in a
different costume and hope the viewer
won't notice that nothing has actually
changed
but rest assured it's not all doom and
gloom from the series
somewhat counter-intuitively the show
has managed to fight this stasis by well
taking a gigantic leap back to how
things used to be
what happens is season 11 sees archer
awake from his coma
and ready to resume his role at isis the
spy agency which is somehow back in
operation
working out of the same old building
with the same old staff as if nothing
ever happened
almost as if miraculously saving us from
the minor failures of the previous three
seasons
this kind of hard reset might seem like
an admission of defeat
like the band who realizes none of its
new material is working so agrees to
just play the hits from now on but it's
already done
a much better job at keeping the show
fresh than the coma seasons
ever did while the surface details are
the same as early seasons
the deeper layers are vitally different
archer is forced to reintegrate himself
into a team that
no longer really needs him cyril is now
a super spy
lana is married and the whole agency is
vastly more ethical
efficient and cost-effective than it
ever was when he was there
i'm just going by the book and archer a
man
pathologically in need of attention has
to learn to live in a world that he's
not the center of even his favorite
group
jokes have gone out of fashion whoa
sploosh right
oh yeah we don't do that anymore you
don't
what sploosh you you have to sploosh you
all sploosh
everybody splooshes i do not sploosh
these shifts and power dynamics create
changes which are actually
far more meaningful than any of the
alternate setting seasons could yield
and as a result we see new sides to each
character
cyril is an obsessively sculpted mass of
muscle built on a foundation of
raging insecurity oh geezy petes
that keeps happening the dangers of
increased muscle mass i guess
lana has achieved the sort of peace
companionship and professionalism in her
life that she
always thought she wanted pam who began
as the hapless hrf
has become a self-assured competent
emotionally aware member of the team
it's been three years numbnuts we've had
a whole thing going without you
can't you just make an effort to fit
yourself in
and beyond that the show even manages to
transform
the ongoing anxiety about backsliding
from problem
into a major theme we must keep moving
forward a meta turn which allows it to
effectively self-analyze without
disappearing up its own ass completely
but what do you think wisecrack did you
enjoy the creative freedom that the
comatose seasons provided or would you
rather see archer keep his eyes open
from now on
let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our patrons as
always and try not to spill anything
while you hit that subscribe button
because that is how you get ants also
ring that bell
it won't give you tinnitus and of course
thanks for watching
[Music]
later
[Music]